one thing I did realize working with
Dominico is kind of like what Dominico
says he just really just doesn't like we
presented a lot of stuff that looked
like the church and then they almost
created like a church
we let some details go that
I think people would be surprised with
yeah we just wanted to get married we
didn't yeah really care about the
details I remember calling Melissa
Culkin planning it in 30 minutes and
then calling you and talking to you
about it we were like yeah perfect
when like everything else that I do is
so planned out and so
detailed like we provided like the
feeling and the vibe
and then like really trusted Dominico to
like
carry it out we really just wanted it to
feel authentic
[Music]